bien et pour ce club des territoires un
club spécial consacré aux violences dans
le foot pourquoi parce que Mathias
bonjour Mathias bonjour vous avez
réalisé un reportage violence dans le
foot la coupe est pleine c'est diffusé
demain à 18h30 sur notre antenne
évidemment sur ce sujet des violences
dans le foot on va en regarder quelques
extraits pendant ce club et avec nous
pour en parler Bertrand Latour bonjour
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
journaliste à la chaîne l'équipe on vous
retrouve tous les jours à 15h50 dans
l'équipe de choc et Pierre barteléi
bonjour merci d'être là avoc d'associ
de supporters et en visio avec nous à
distance Jean inret le sénateur
centriste des vuges bonjour monsieur INR
merci également d'être avec nous vous
êtes dans le documentaire de Mathias et
puis vous avez posé plusieurs questions
fait des propositions au Sénat sur le
sujet on va vous entendre évidemment
dans quelques instants vous nous direz
comment on peut expliquer ces violences
dans le foot comment lutter les
interdictions de supporters ne
sont-elles pas une solution de facilité
toutes ces questions sur lesquelles on
attend vos
réponses
d'abord Mathias on va commencer avec
vous pourquoi vous avez choisi de
traiter ce sujet des violences dans le
foot bah parce que c'est un sujet qui se
rappelle toujours à notre bon souvenir
il y a pas plus tard que que 10 jours il
y a eu des incident pendant un match
entre Bordeaux et Nice des supporters
qui sont affrontés avant ça on avait
tous déjà été choqués l'été dernier au
moment de l'agression du jeune Kenzo un
enfant supporter de l'OM lors du
déplacement de son équipe à à Ajax il a
ensuite eu l'agression de de William et
sa famille pour pour le match Nant
Marseille William qui avait fait à ce
moment-là deux infartus voilà
globalement c'est des sujets ça concerne
plus que le foot maintenant c'est des
sujets de société qui intéressent tout
le monde et puis plus globalement je
suis moi-même personnel personnellement
supporter de foot donc il y a un moment
il y avait un peu un un ralbol qui
s'exprimait on voulait comprendre
pourquoi ces violences existaient et
sortir un peu du manikéisme qui veut que
d'un côté toute la faute revient aux
autorités et à la la doctrine de gestion
de l'ORD dans les stades ou de l'autre
côté qui dit que les supporters sont
simplement des bœs et que ils se mettent
toujours les uns sur les autres ouais
justement on va parler de tout ça
Bertrand Latour c'est devenu un sujet de
société comme l'a dit Mathias est-ce que
c'est violence dans le sport elles sont
propres au foot ou en tout cas elles
sont accrues dans le foot ouais ell le
sont davantage ça c'est une c'est une
évidence il y a des des événements qu'on
voit se reproduire main main de fois
dans le foot qu'on voit pas dans
d'autres dans d'autres sports le weekend
dernier je suis allé voir un match de de
rugby entre le Racing et le Stade
Toulousain les supporters cohabitent
ensemble après le match il y a une bég
les supporters boivent des verres
ensemble ça paraî difficile à vivre dans
le foot c'est le vrai problème c'est qu'
a l'impression que ça s'empire année
après année il y peut-être et ça pire
aussi bien passer pour en parler mais un
avant un après covid l'impression qu'il
y a quand même une hausse de la violence
souvent que le foot est le reflet de la
société c'est peut-être un peu simpliste
comme raisonnement mais c'est pas si
loin que ça de la vérité et c'est vrai
que le foot génère des des excès
positifs à la fois il y a pas d'autres
événements et on peut le regretter qui
permettent de rassembler autant de de
gens sur les Champs-Élysées quand la
France gagne et à l'inverse il y a peu
de manifestations qui divise aussi
autant les les supporteurs en tout cas
les les citoyens quoi ouais pierre
justement est-ce que Pierre bartelémi
est-ce que vous avez constaté des violen
est-ce que ces violences dans le foot
elles sont en hausse alors il y a
effectivement une hausse au retour après
le H cl post covid notamment lié à des
phénomènes de société évoqués par
mertran mais aussi lié à des problèmes
de de organisation il fallait reprendre
les bons réflexes d'organisation en
revanche cette saison par rapport à la
saison dernière on constate une baisse
des incidents mais une hausse des
incidents graves donc c'est ça qui est
paradoxal c'estàdire qu'on en entend
davantage parler parce que ce sont des
incidents plus graves et plus
médiatiques mais généralement les
rencontres se passent nettement mieux
que l'année précédente c'est toute ce ce
cette difficulté aussi de ne de ne pas
trop se concentrer sur des incidents
isolés pour leur donner une portée plus
générale un chiffre il y a 13 millions
de personnes qui vont voir des matchs de
Ligue 1 et Ligue 2 chaque saison l'an
dernier il y a eu 200 11 16
interpellations pour violence donc ça
reste des ratios très faibles mais c'est
pas pour ça que c'est acceptable et
c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut pas
continuer à lutter en amont pour éviter
ces incidents et en après en aval après
pour sanctionner durement les personnes
qui ont ses comportementséprochou pertr
effectivement fa faut le dire ça reste
quand même très minoritaire bien sûr que
c'est c'est minoritaire après ce qui est
souvent moi je trouve assez
insupportable c'est que le le focus il
est mis en fonction de l'intérêt de de
la rencontre c'estàdire que selon si ça
concerne Marseille Lyon Paris Benjamin
ou des équipes qui sont moins connu en
Ligue 1 ou en Ligue 2 le focus est moins
important ça ça tient mon avis de la
part des politiques qui quand c'est un
match important vont s'en apparer plus
facilement et pour certains se font de
la publicité là-dessus et pour d'autres
et j'en prends aussi une partie de la
responsabilité parce que je fais partie
des médias nous aussi en parlons
davantage quand ça concerne Marseille
Paris ou Lyon davantage que quand un
samedi après-midi de Coupe de France
comme c'est arrivé début janvier il y a
des incidents entre bordelay et nissois
c'est un match diffusé sur bin max twet
que personne ne regarde on en parle
moins c'est pas pour autant que c'est
moins grave mais c'est vrai que le focus
médiatique est moins important aussi ça
je trouve que c'est unentiel et c'est
une question vous avez raison de le dire
c'est une question de focus médiatique
ou ou c'est concentré quand même dans
certains clubs ou est-ce que finalement
ça touche plusieurs clubs bah ça touche
plusieurs clubs c'est une évidence après
on peut aussi considérer que plus il y a
de supporters plus il y a de risque
aussi queil y ait des incidents et il y
a certains clubs qui reviennent c'est
vrai que ces derniers temps Marseille
Lyon Lyon est souvent revenu au devant
de de l'actualité après il y a des
problèmes différents qui se mêlent on
sait qu' Lyon dans la ville et ça se
reflète aussi dans les associations de
supporter il y a une frange notamment de
de l'extrême droite qui agit énormément
et ça se répercute sur les stades c'est
notamment un des enjeux qui s'était
passé lors du Marseille lion qui avait
pas pu se se disputer il y avait de ça
derrière ouais et et parce qu' aussi
dans ces villes peut-être que les clubs
de foot sont sont l'âme de la ville il
il y a aussi des villes qui qui vivent à
travers leur club de foot Marseille
c'est c'est pas le même Marseille quand
l'OM gagne ou quand l'OM perd oui l'OM
c'est le poumon de la ville d'ailleurs
dans le dans documentaire que j'ai
quelqu que j'ai pu regarder c'est on le
voit et pour quiconque a déjà été à
Marseille se rend bien compte
qu'effectivement l'atmosphère est très
différente selon si ça se passe bien ou
mal dans les tribunes et après la
difficulté aussi pour les clubs c'est de
pouvoir le le gérer les les présidents
notamment les dirigeants doivent à la
fois faire preuve de de de sévérité
faire respecter les règles et en même
temps on face à eux des supporters qui
viennent toutes les semaines sont des
clients ont des moyens aussi euh
d'impacter le fonctionnement du club
donc ils doivent naviguer euh entre ces
deux aspects et c'est pas toujours au
sens de de l'avancée de l'éradication de
ces problèmesl et on va en parler de ça
un petit mot jean inret avec vous merci
d'être avec nous à distance Jean inret
euh on le disait dans le début de ce
club finalement ce qui se passe c'est
aussi le reflet de la société c'est pour
ça que vous avez choisi de vous emparler
de ce sujet
oui c'est un sujet important parce qu'
on on le voit finalement l'image qui est
dégagé à travers tout ce que l'on peut
voir euh à la télévision et même dans
nos émicycles comme ça a été rappelé euh
à l'instant dégage une atmosphère
dégradée même au niveau de nos
territoires et ce matin nous sommes dans
le club des territoires je pense que ce
qui est important c'est de voir que
l'image qui est donnée par ces
supporters aussi parfois le fait que le
politique ne s'empare pas totalement du
sujet avec un manque de responsabilité
collective va impacter directement
l'image du foot dans nos territoires
auprès de nos enfants de nos petits
enfants qui jouent au foot dans des
clubs et on le verra dans le reportage
je pense de Mathias que cela aussi
dégrade l'image que peuvent avoir les
jeunes du football le comportement se
dégrade aussi dans nos territoire et
c'est ça qui est important à soulever ce
matin et justement Mathias on va
regarder un premier extrait de votre
reportage le le témoignage d'un père de
famille oui William et et sa femme
Alicia qui avait décidé d'emmener leur
fils Marius 6 ans pour la première fois
au stade alors pour remettre un peu de
contexte ils sont Nanta mais ils sont
supporters de l'OM l'équipe passe dans
dans la région il décident d'aller
d'aller bah au match pour faire plaisir
à leur fils et au bout de 4 minutes
Marseille marque ils sont donc dans une
tribune famille à côté d'une tribune
avec des ultr Nanta et là forcément bah
c'est c'est un drame comme nous l'a
expliqué
William mon fils s'est levé sur le siège
et et à but et et ça leura pas plu et et
ils sont arrivés déferl en lui jetant
l'insultant homme et femme en
l'insultant lui crachant dessus et euh
c'était vraim je comme je dis je crois
qu'on ne sait même pas le nombre de
bières de PIST de crachat qu'il y a eu
dans cette violence puisque ça allait
très très vite bah ce que nous décrit
William là c'est arrivé deux autres fois
avant avant la mi-temps à chaque fois il
s'est interposé pour protéger sa famille
à tel point que il est tellement monté
dans les tours qu'il a fait un double
infartus William donc c'est c'est un
miracle que il s'en sorte parce que il y
a il y avait des équipes de soignants
qui étaient dans le stade et qui ont pu
intervenir très vite mais c'est
notamment l'un des incidents forts de
ces derniers mois qui avait interpellé
les politiques et déjà à l'époque Amélie
casterra leur avait témoigné leur
soutien et elle avait décidé de monter
au créneau ouais est-ce qu'on on envoie
de plus en plus des alors ça reste
évidemment une exception mais quand même
là on entend ce témoignage c'est assez
poignant est-ce qu'on envoit de plus en
plus des violences de ce type qui sont
des violences très
graves paradoxalement non il y en a il y
en a de moins en moins mais il y a des
elles sont beaucoup plus graves puisque
là la première fois le le petit Kenzo
ben c'est un enfant malade qui est
attaqué dans une loge là c'est le père
de famille qui fait qui fait un double
infactus donc les conséquences et et les
faits sont très graves mais c'est
vraiment tout le paradoxe la qualité des
travaux menés en prévention des
rencontres et aussi des des sanctions de
plus en plus ciblées ont permis de
justement de réduire ce nombre
d'incidents donc les outils fonctionnent
euh ce qui malheureusement n'empêche pas
des des situations graves et on le voit
sur d'autres d'Ares phénom de société il
peut y avoir des manifestations sociale
dans la rue qui se passe très très bien
mais il va y avoir un incident très
grave qui va toucher 0,01 % des
manifestants et ça va jeter le discrédit
à la fois sur cette manifestation mais
aussi sur tout le mouvement social donc
c'est c'est tout le paradoxe de du du
focus sur euh sur un incident grave ça
ça reste des exceptions mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui le visage des supporters
a a changé a évolué il a il y a plus de
radicalité je suis pas sûr parce que
aujourd'hui il y a un niveau de dialogue
qui a jamais eu dans le football
français que ce soit au niveau national
les les groupes de supporters sont
représentés dans ce qu'on appelle
l'instance nationale du sportterisme qui
est rattaché au ministère des Sports
donc il y a un vrai dialogue sur tous
les sujets sans tabou et au niveau local
on a créé enfin c'est le la la loi de de
2016 qui a créé ça notamment ça a été
rajouté par le Sénat euh le référent
supporter c'estàd c'est un salarié ou un
bénévole du club qui est chargé de la
relation entre le club et les supporters
et ça ça a créé un vrai dialogue avec
des relations de confiance puisque ce
poste ne fonctionne que s'il y a une
relation de confiance et dans j'ai envie
dire 90 % des clubs où il y a un
référent supporter qui fait correctement
son travail les tensions ont baissé et
les incidents ont baisser on le voit ça
ça change aussi évidemment l'image des
supporters en tout cas dans la société
puisque comme vous dites Bertrand nous
les médias on relait évidemment ces
incidents dans le reportage de Mathias
on voit cette banderole des supporters
lançois qui disent supporters pas
criminel c'est aussi ça le risque de
stigmatiser les supporters de foot je
crois que c'est déjà le cas je suis pas
sûr que les supporters de foot d'une
manière générale et une énorme code de
popularité pour ceux qui suivent ces
affaires là de de très loin et c'est
évidemment que chaque affaire chaque
incident vient chaque fois détériorer
dégrader l'image que pe avir les
supporters moi ils n'ont pas me
convaincre c'est mon univers je sais
parfaitement que évidemment quand il y a
60 000 personnes qui sont dans un stade
au stade Vélodrome il y a pas 60000
abruti bien au contraire mais il suffit
qu'il y en ait 50 ou 100 pour que il
puisse causer des dégâts qui soit
immense moi ce que j'aimerais et ce que
j'attends notamment de la part des clubs
et aussi des politiques de l'État c'est
que ça puisse avancer et
l'identification comment est-ce qu'on
peut mieux la gérer parce que fermer des
tribunes c'est c'est c'est très bien et
ça fait des des mesures qui sont
percutantes mais qui au final pénalisent
énormément de gens pour qu'à la fin
potentiellement le 15 jours après il y
en a à nouveau 10 autres qui
reproduisent les les mêmes choses mon
avis c'est c'est là dessus qu'il faut
avancer je pense qu'en 2024 on doit être
en capacité de pouvoir davantage
identifier sanctionner peut-être plus
durement aussi pour que ça soit pour que
ça invite les gens à éviter de de
recommencer quoi et ça veut dire faire
peut-être plus de sanctions individuelle
parce que là on a l'impression que quand
il y a un incident la réponse c'est on
interdit les déplacements de supporter
est-ce que c'est un peu la la solution
de facilité bah c'est la c'est la preuve
d'un constat d'échec c'estd qu'on
puisque nous ne sommes pas
capables d'empêcher les problèmes d'une
autre manière interdisons tout et comme
ça on a plus de souci c'est une réponse
mais est-ce qu'elle est suffisante je
suis pas je suis pas certain il y a eu
un un moratoire il y a de cela quelques
temps que final les décisions au Conseil
d'État ont été cassées en en très très
régulièrement effectivement moi je pense
que l'individualisation c'est ce vers
quoi il faut davantage
tendre oui bah justement on a rencontré
la ministre Amélie Ouda casterra dans le
cadre de ce documentaire alors on remet
dans contexte à l'époque elle était que
ministre des Sports elle était pas
encore dans la dans dans la tourmente et
elle venait donc de prendre cette
décision du moratoire dont parle
Bertrand parce que selon elle et ben
elle avait déjà tendu la main aux
supporters pour le dialogue pour trouver
des solutions et elle dénonce une d'une
certaine manière une politique de la
chaise vide he de la part des supporters
cette envie de dialogue je l'ai main de
fois démontré maintenant ce que
j'attends des associations de supporter
c'est qu'elle dénonce ces faits de
violence je les ai pas entendu là depuis
Nant
je les ai pas entendu dénoncer je les ai
vu faire des recours contre des mesures
d'interdiction de déplacement j'aurais
aimé qu'elle concentre aussi une part de
leur attention pour dénoncer ces faits
de violence c'est légitime ce que ce que
dit la ministre là elle a
raison oui et non c'està direire que
l'association de la cell porter a
régulièrement dénoncé des incidents
graves quand on prend son compte Twitter
on peut voir les communiqués sur ce qui
s'est passé à Nice à Nant Nice c'est
vrai que l'association mais
l'association s'en est justifié auprès
de la ministre en privé en expliquant
que tout le monde était dans
l'association était traumatisé les les
gens ne se sont plus parlés dans
l'association pendant 2 semaines
tellement ils étaient sous le choc il y
a trois Nanta dans le bureau de
l'association et donc c'est simplement
que il y a pas eu de réflexe dans
l'association enfin il y a pas il y a
pas de connaissance politique de sens
politique c'est des bénévoles des
supporters ils ont communiqué
publiquement pour condamner c'était
enfin ça ne leur ait pas venu à l'esprit
donc c'est pas qu'il les approuvaent
c'est simplement que ils étaient dans
une phase de choc à laquelle il n'était
pas préparé et ça a été clairement
expliqué à la ministre euh pour autant
ça ne justifiait pas des mesures
collectives qui frappaient les
déplacements de de dizaines de milliers
de personnes en France et ce qui a
justifié de non pas de de contestation
non pas de rébellion mais de juste de
saisine du juge administratif Avin que
le juge se prononce sur la légalité de
ces de ces décisions mais c'est un peu
sévère de la part de ministre de la
ministre de le présenter comme ça sur
qu'en plus nantenis c'est vraiment un
cas très particulier puis que c'est un
chauffeur de VTC qui sort de son de son
VTC avec un couteau qui essaie de de de
poignarder un maximum de de de supporter
face à lui donc certes il y a un
contexte de rivalité entre groupe de
supporters mais c'est une personne
tierce au monde des supporterismes qui
vient avec une arme et qui crée cet
incident donc c'était vraiment en plus
un incident très isolé par rapport à
ceux où il y a vraiment une
responsabilité à 100 % des supporters
après ce qu'elle essaie de souligner
aussi entre les lignes là c'est qu'il y
a un problème de responsabilité générale
on avait aussi parlé avec elle du bus de
Lyon qui a été caillassé à à Marseille
et que à ce moment-là bah tout le monde
se jette la patate chaude il y a pas de
responsable forcément untel n'appartient
pas au groupe c'est un peu difficile
aussi d' les responsabilités de chacun
alors il y a deux sujets il y a la
responsabilité au sein des acteurs
c'est-à-dire par exemple sur la voie
publique est-ce que c'est l'état ou
est-ce que c'est le club qui est
responsable ce qui change beaucoup de
choses et après il y a effectivement la
question de qui est-ce qu'il faut
sanctionner ou qui est-ce qu' doit
assumer quand il y a un incident du côté
des supporters et là il y a une clarté
enfin vraiment une transparence côté
supporter il faut des sanctions
individuelles pourquoi d'abord parce que
c'est la seule sanction juste et ensuite
parce que c'est la seuleance sanction
efficace c'estàdire qu'aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui va commettre un acte
criminel dans un stade il se te dit bah
au prochain match il y aura un H clos ça
va me coûter qu'un seul match et je
reviens mais ça va pénaliser 50000
personnes celui celui qui sait que on va
l'identifier qu'on va l'arrêter qui va
passer en procès et qui va être interdit
stade pendant 5 ans qui va aller pointer
au commissariat 60 fois par an à chaque
match de son équipe il va pas se dire
c'est juste un match et et puis pour le
coup vraiment quand vous devez pointer
60 fois par an dans le casre d'une
interdiction de stade vous n'avez plus
de vie sociale c'est donc ça ça marque
fort 5 ans 5 ans sans vie sociale vous
savez partir en vacances pas partir en
weekend parce que vous con sa pas les
horaires des matchs vous savez pas quand
vous allez devoir aller pointer au
commissariat ou demander une dérogation
sur votre lieu de vacances c'est
colossal Jean INRP pardon puisque vous
êtes avec nous à distance Jean sur les
mesures à prendre il faut aller vers une
plus forte individualisation des
sanctions et pas vers des sanctions
globales qui touchent tous les
supporters ou qui touchent tout un stade
quand il y a des matchs à
wiclot on voit que les sanctions
globales ont leur limite et ce qui vient
d'être rappelé par le dernier
intervenant maître c'est que les
sanctions individuelles ne sont pas
assez fortes lorsque en France on a des
sanctions parfois en moyenne de 3 6 mois
sur les interdictions de stade alors
qu'en Angleterre et le le reportage le
montrera desè samedis c'est 5 ans 10 ans
d'interdiction de stade avec le le
devoir d'aller pointer pour les
supporters à la police et ce qui empêche
les individus de venir dans les stades
si les Anglais ils sont arrivés je vois
pas pourquoi en France on y arriverait
pas mais je pense que ça correspond
aussi à un problème de laxisme
d'ambiance générale et que ce qui se
passe dans les stades se passe aussi
dans le reste de la société il faut des
sanctions plus fortes au niveau
individuel et arrêter aussi de
stigmatiser les groupes de supporters
dans les groupes de supporters c'est
comme dans toute société vous avez des
individus béliqueux qui cause des
problèmes et vous avez le 3/4 des gens
qui sont là pour supporter leur club de
foot et il y a de nombreux supporters
autour de la table ce matin je pense que
quand on aime son club on aime aussi les
gens et on n' pas envie de causer des
débordements les sanctions individuelles
doivent être plus fortes ber toi oui il
y a deux réflexions que minpire cette
conversation déjà la première c'est que
les interdictions de déplacement de
supporters elles sont aussi prises par
les politiques dans un contexte où les
Jeux Olympiques 2024 arrivent je sais ce
que pense un certain nombre de
dirigeants que j'ai régulièrement au
téléphone pour une autre actualité un
peu plus joyeuse en terme de de foot
c'est que c'est aussi un moyen de se
dire en interdisant les déplacement on
est sûr de pas avoir de problème et ça
remet pas en question l'organisation de
nos jeux olympiques ou les mois on s'en
rapproche à chaque fois un peu plus en
se disant on est incapable d'organiser
des manifestations là comme ça il ne se
passe rien et ça remet pas le sujet sur
la table de manière indéfini en se
disant on est incapable de gérer ça
c'est aussi un moyen de s'en assurer
pour le regretter mais c'est aussi comme
ça je pense que les les politiques
fonctionnent après sur le modèle anglais
évidment je souscris ce qui a été dit
c'est vrai que pour ce qui est de
l'élite de la première ligue c'est il y
a eu aussi au moment où ils ont traité
ces affaires là une Haos des tarifs je
suis pas sûr qu'on est exactement la
même clientèle en première ligue qu'en
qu'en Ligue 1 mais attention tion à ne
pas idéaliser le modèle anglais ils ont
réglé certains problèmes ils les ont
peut-être aussi un peu déplacés soit
dans des divisions inférieures ou avec
leur équipe nationale on sait que quand
les Anglais pour ce qui est de la
sélection anglaise se déplacent ils sont
extrêmement dangereux il y a eu un
certain nombre de problèmes notamment
lors du dernier EUR organisé en France
entre Anglais et russes donc les
problèmes qu'il n'ont plus avec le club
parfois il le retrouve avec la sélection
nationale donc voilà ouais on va on
parle dans quelques secondes justement
de l'exemple britannique puisque Mathias
vous vous êtes rendu au Royaume-Uni mais
juste un mot Bertrand Latour sur ce que
vous nous disiez tout à l'heure sur le
poids des supporters au sein des clubs
qui font partie de l'économie du club
est-ce que c'est difficile pour les
clubs pour les dirigeants de club de
s'pposer à leurs supporters et d'avoir
une autorité forte sur ces supporters
oui moi je trouve qu'il y a parfois un
double jeu qui est mené par les
dirigeants et je je le dis en tant
qu'observateur et c'est c'est assez
facile pour moi de de porter ce jugement
là mais c'est très difficile pour eux
d'être extrêmement sévère avec des gens
qui sont des clients et qui mettent
l'ambiance et ce parfois nous aussi on
est très content de pouvoir faire des
bandesannonces avec des fumigènes des
ambiances très fortes il sait qu'ils
sont interdits en France et on les
utilise aussi donc il y a parfois aussi
une schizophrénie de notre part à nous
mais et avec des supporters qui peuvent
impacter directement ou indirectement
les résultats de leur équipe c'estàdire
que si vous avez un groupe de supporters
parfois à Marseille il y a des groupes
où il y a 1000 2000 3000 supporters qui
ont décidé de mettre une ambiance qui
est moins positive ça se retourne contre
eux et le président du du club de
supporters il a intéresst ce que les
matchs passent bien mais il aussi
intéresst que son son équipe fonctionne
bien donc il faut à la fois
faire des arbitrages entre ce qu'on
autorise aux supporters etah le fait que
les les matchs évidemment se déroulent
dans le calme et la paix donc c'est
c'est pas toujours évident et on peut
pas non plus leur demander de tout gérer
c'est là aussi que l'État aussi
également doit prendre sa place quand
même quoi pierreber vous qui côyez
beaucoup d'associations de supporter
est-ce que ils sont conscients qu'ils
sont en position de force finalement les
supporters au sein des clubs
aujourd'hui-ils jou un peu je pense
qu'il y a aussi des fantasmes là-dessus
parce que on constate c'est que quand un
club veut vraiment serrer la vie s'il le
fait fait et les supporterurs ont pas
beaucoup de Levi si ce n'est des
banderolles et cetera donc non en
revanche il y a un point très important
qui a été abordé là c'est de dire que il
faut arrêter de transférer de plus en
plus la responsabilité sur les clubs et
sur la Ligue c'est ce qu'on entend
beaucoup la dans comme dans tout le
reste de la société lorsque quelqu'un se
comporte mal commet un délit la première
autorité qui doit agir c'est la police
et ensuite c'est la justice et
aujourd'hui comme après avoir créé
l'interdiction judiciaire de stade on a
créé l'interdiction administrative dans
les mains du préfet puis maintenant
l'interdiction commerciale dans les
mains du club et que dans le même temps
la Ligue prend des grand clos qui qui
qui font parler qui est médiatique on a
l'impression que la police et la justice
qu' sait déborder ils ont vraiment mais
des choses beaucoup plus graves à gérer
avec énormément de dossiers un manque de
moyens mais ils se disent bon bah
puisque les clubs peuvent prendre des
mesures individuelles mais sans les
moyens d'identification que nous on a et
puisque la Ligue prend des mesures
collectives avec des huclloss on n plus
trop à s'embêter à identifier
individuellement à sanctionner
individuellement et c'est là je pense
aujourd'hui le le point principal pour
faire des efforts c'est que l'autorité
légitime pour sanctionner celle qui qui
qui a les compétences les moyens et la
légitimité démocratique et juridique
c'est la police c'est la justice et donc
il faut leur redonner les moyens de
faire le ménage peut-être que ça va être
une concentration de moyens très forte
pendant quelques années mais que ça va
régler 90 % du problème donc donner plus
de responsabilité par exemple à la
police dans les stade ce qui est pas
forcément le cas aujourd'hui ça peut
être une solution je pense qu'ils ont
les moyens d'identifier sans donner plus
de responsabilité dans les stades
aujourd'hui ce qui a été constaté c'est
que sur les les phénomènes plus globaux
c'est pour éviter les mouvements de
foule les incidents dans des dans c'est
passe très contraint comme un stade
c'est mieux que ça soit les stadiers
parce qu'ils sont formés pour ça et
parce qu'ils connaissent les supporters
et donc il y a il y a une plus plus
grande facilité mais quand il y a des
incidents graves quand il le faut la
police a le droit d'entrer avec l'accord
du club dans dans le stade pour
intervenir donc je suis pas sûr que
mettre des uniformes de police partout
dans un stade ça soit la solution ça
peut peut-être plus créer de tension
qu'utre chose en revanche quand une
personne se comporte mal et par exemple
l qu'il y a des cris de singe et des
Salus naasis dans le parquage Lyonnais à
Marseille ça m'aurait semblé naturel que
la police rentre dans le parquage
interpelle les 5 si personnes les
sortent et et on aurait réglé le probl
problème on aurait identifié là on
demande au club d'identifier 3 semaines
après sur des caméras qui sont pas les
siennes puisque c'était pas le club qui
recevait le match Lyon d'aller
identifier derrière des cagoules des
personnes la police elle sera allé les
chercher enfin il y a plus plus
d'identification à faire par le club
Mathias on revient sur l'exemple du
Royaume-Uni on en parlait ouais
justement les Anglais se basent sur un
modèle très sociologique alors on a
rencontré Marc Robert qui est le chef
d'une police dédiée au foot au
Royaume-Uni alors il nous a expliquer
que dans les grandes lignes au stade
entre 70 et 80 % des supporters viennent
et ne poseront jamais de problème me à
l'inverse il y a 5 % des gens c'est un
peu maniquin qui viendront quoi qu'il
arrive pour faire le mal ça c'est un
modèle très anglo-saxon et puis au
milieu il y a un petit groupe flottant
qui peut basculer d'un côté ou de
l'autre sont sous l'influence de la
drogue de l'alcool ou si ils ressentent
par exemple et ben une une doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre trop serré trop trop
dur avec eux et donc on a aussi
rencontré Jof pearon qui est un
professeur de droit à l'Université de
Manchester qui est spécialiste de ces
questions et nous expliquer qu'en fait
bah dans le modèle français on avait on
avait un mauvaise approche du du
problème
je pense que les Français ont de graves
problèmes en term de gestion des foules
et ces problèmes ont pris de l'ampleur
ces dernièr
annp problèmeance maintien de l'ordre
matchotall comme des é d're publicès
risque les gendarmes pas l'expéri néire
pourler les
fou apoche basée sur le dialogue que
nous savons être les plus efficaces avec
le public du foot en fait à l'occasion
de ce de ce déplacement on a assisté à
un match entre le Manchester United et
le Bayern Munich sur le papier non mais
sur le papier on peut dire c'est en plus
il y avait des enux il y avait des
enjeux sportifs tout ça on peut se dire
il va avoir des tensions entre les
supporters mais en fait les Anglais ont
fait un tel travail de renseignement
qu'il sont dit bah les muniois ils vont
pas poser de problème donc on a été
assez surpris de voir qu'il y avait très
peu de CRS très peu de policiers pour
encadrer les munikois et à l'inverse on
a aussi suivi bah la sécurisation d'un
match entre Marseille et clermontte n on
nous explique que les supporters
clermontois sont des agneaux qui aura
pas de problème mais on les fait rentrer
dans le stade 3h avant encadré par des
CRS en fait on sent quand même un
décalage entre le travail de
renseignement et derrière la doctrine
appliquée pour encadrer les supporter
c'est oui mais l'exemple il est très
parlant je je crois qu'il est il est
assez bien trouvé effectivement mais
d'ailleurs si on avait la bonne approche
je pense qu'on aurait on aurait moins de
soucis que ce qui est le cas
actuellement effectivement après
le ça passe par un dialogue je pense
plus important encore avec les
supporters et Pierre disait que c'est de
plus en plus le cas et je pense que il
faut tendre et aller aller vers ça mais
moi je comprends aussi que quand il y a
des exemples qui
viennent mettre en brècheche toute une
politique et
que l'État en fait se rassure peut-être
aussi de cette manière là en se disant
plus on met de plus on met de de police
et moins il y aura de souc on s'aperçoit
que c'est pas la bonne approche ce qu'on
aimit c'est que ça puisse changer que
au-delà en fait des grand grande
déclaration à chaque fois qu' a eu un
problème au lendemain chacun s'indigne
et que en fait la semaine qui suit de
semaines après 15 jours rien n'a
vraiment changé en fait ouais Jean il
faut s'inspirer de de cet exemple
anglais mais le problème c'est pas un
problème de moyen mise en œuvre par
l'État je pense que une fois de plus on
demande beaucoup trop de choses à l'état
et que les clubs de supporters moi je
serais à l'inverse d'un des intervenants
précédents qui disait que les club de
supporters devaent laisser plus de place
à l'état pour sécuriser les stades moi
je pense P qu'il faut que l'État laisse
plus de place au club pour sécuriser les
stades et l'espace public parce que
c'est aussi une question de coût je ne
vois pas pourquoi le football prend une
place si importante dans les coups
engendrés en terme de sécurité alors que
les Français voient très bien que dans
d'autres sports ça se passe très bien on
a donné l'exemple du rugby tout à
l'heure on l'a vu pendant la coupe du
monde il n y a quasiment pas eu
d'incident alors que tous les weekends
dans notre stade de foot il y a des
problèmes donc il faut vraiment aussi
que les clubs prennent leur part on l'a
vu à Marseille il y a des dispositifs de
sécurité très important
même pour des matchs un peu plus un peu
plus tranquill on va dire comme c'était
le cas à Clairmont où les dispositifs
sont vraiment très important Matha dit
quand les clubs de supporter clermontoi
arrivent 3h avant son parquet ça peut
créer aussi un côté anxiogène donc les
clubs doivent prendre un peu plus de de
leur part du travail dans ce système de
sécurité
Bertrand j'entends mais je suis pas
d'accord quand on est Pablo Longoria
Nass Khalifi avant toute chose on est là
quand même pour gérer un club de
football faire en sorte de recruter des
bons joueurs que votre stade soit plein
et avoir la meilleur résultat possible
et l'autre face c'est bien évidemment
c'est que les les matchs passent bien
mais on peut pas leur demander vers ça
c'est ni le ministre de la justice ni un
préfet P de l'OM et du PSG exactement on
on est ni ni ni un préfet donc il a un
moment donné on peut pas tout le leur
demander non plus après effectivement
que dans d'autres sports ça se passe m
on est d'accord c'est un état de fait
évidemment on l'a dit en rugby par
exemple exemple qu' a un sport qui
génère énormément de monde et les stades
sont pleins et sont importants il y a
pas ces souc là ça on est d'accord
là-dessus mais on je pense qu'on peut
pas trop en demander non plus et il faut
que chacun assume ses responsabilités
mais il y a il y a deux choses hein
c'estàdire que nous côté supporter on
demande davantage d'intervention de la
police et la justice c'est dans la
répression c'est-à-dire une fois qu'il y
a eu des incidents l'autorité légitime
pour sanctionner c'est la police et la
justice en revanche que chacun et sa
part dans l'organisation la préparation
des matchs c'est clair que les clubs et
les groupes de supporters ont leur part
de responsabilités et doivent
s'impliquer dans ce dialogue un dernier
mot ma ben un dialogue qui va
s'articuler normalement dans les
semaines qui viennent parce que la
ministre Amélie ou casterra a proposé de
des Assises du football pour repenser
aussi la bah la gouvernance du foot on
sait qu'elle a la LFP un peu en ligne de
mire et d'ailleurs je pense que le
sénateur ingr il participera voilà et on
suivra évidemment tout ça merci à tous
merci à tous d'avoir participé à débat
si vous voulez bien rester avec nous on
va voir ce qu' la une de nos quotidiens
régionaux Quentin nous
[Musique]
rejoint
le retour de Quentin Quentin on regarde
ce qu' une de nos cotidiens régionaux
évidemment ce matin la une de la presse
régionale beaucoup de tiit se demandent
si la crise agricole est terminée oui
pas mal de points d'interrogation ce
matin effectivement à l'ne de la presse
régionale est-ce une sortie de crise se
demande Le Bé républicain à Bourg la fin
des blocages titre Le Dauphin libéré à
Grenoble c'est la même une pour le Midi
Libre à Montpellier la charante libre
qui titre sur le marché conclut entre
hatal et la FNSEA globalement on lit que
les syndicats d'agriculteurs ont été
rassurés par les nouvelles mesures pour
osé par le gouvernement même si
certaines fédérations départementales de
la FNSEA restent mobilisé ainsi que le
3ème syndicat agricool c'est la
Confédération paysane on continue sur ce
thème oui beaucoup de HES ce matin je
vous le disais dans les régions avec une
question qui ressort vainqueur de la
séquence à anger le Courrier de l'Ouest
parle du tour de force des agriculteurs
globalement la pression baisse d'un cran
dans le pays à la lecture des journaux
même si l'ardénis nuance il reste sur
leurgadee garde même idée dans Ouest
France les syndicat majoritel appelle à
lever les blocages mais attendent des
résultats concrets avec cette photo sur
la rocade de Renn et ses mots tagués sur
des passerelles en lettre capitale
dessinée à la peinture blanche manger
français Atal fait sauter les barrages
c'est le titre de la voie du Nord selon
Bercy les mesures d'urgen pour les
agriculteurs représenteraient quelques
400 millions d'euros au total monsieur
hatal a évoqué jeudi 150 millions
d'euros en soutien fiscal et social aux
éleveurs beauovvin dans les pages
intérieures on lit dans le journal et
bien les derniers coups de pression de
la F sa hier dans le Nord qui se sont
rapprochés de la frontière belge un
dernier saut de sauterelle pour
maintenir la pression raconte la voie du
Nord on parle unee autre mobilisation
celle des enseignants une école en crise
titre Le Populaire du centre ce matin en
ignant sur deux en grvier en Haute
Vienne c'était 20 % dans toute la France
a fait savoir le ministère d'éducation
nationale les enseignants mobilisés hier
font part de leur colère extrêmement
profonde avec beaucoup de de pancartes
aussi dans les cortèges pour réclamer le
départ d'Amélie oua Castera vous en
parlez dans votre débat fragilisé depuis
3 semaines par les polémiques allez on
parlait rugby Bertrand un rappel Quentin
pour les amateurs de rugby voilà ça va
se jouer à Marseille ce soir match
d'ouverture du tournoi desesstination
pour les Bleus la France affronte
l'Irlande le choc des revanchards titre
même sud-ouest la France est frustrée
d'avoir été éliminé en quart lors de la
Coupe du monde de rugby pareil pour
l'Irlande éliminé souvenez-vous par la
Nouvelle-Zélande alors vous là les
footeux les Fox vous allez
regarder on va repartir vous allez
regarder le match ré ce soir ah moi je
vais regarder avec la plus grande
atttention je suis assez excité parce
que sais qu'on les a quitté sur une
image négative face à l'Afrique du Sud
ça nous rendra pas le titre de champion
du monde mais si on peut commencer du
bon pied on aura fait un bon pas pour
être peut-être gagner le tournoi voilà
Bertrand il est multisport Quentin il
est pas du tout fou il est
rugby
merci merci à tous pour ce débat merci
Jean inret merci Pierre bartelémi merci
Bertrand l tour d'avoir été avec nous on
vous retrouve tous les jours 15h50 sur
la chaîne l'équipe l'équipe de choc et
Mathias votre reportage est à voir
demain sur notre antenne 18h30 violence
dans le foot la coupe est pleine merci
beaucoup merci à tous merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi on vous souhaite un
très bon weekend on se retrouve
lundi